Okay,
so this is the individual instead.
So we have explored territory,
unexplored territory or the known and
the unknown or order and chaos.
And then we have the thing that mediates
between them.
And that's the individual.
And this is of medieval representation,
which I really love.
You know,
there's the dome of the sky there.
It's a very archaic idea that the earth
is a dome because it kind of looks like
that if you go out in a flat field,
you know,
if you're out in the ocean,
the way the world looks like a dome on a
disk.
And so that's sort of the representation
here.
It's a very ancient idea.
And this guy at the bottom left of the
pictures poking his head through the
comprehensible world and looking at the
chaos beyond.
And so he's a heroic figure.
So the knower is the individual is
always the hero of his story,
right?
The protagonist of a story.
Now it can be an antihero too because
just like the known has a negative
element and a pause development and the
unknown has a negative element and a
positive element.
The individual has a negative element
and a positive element.
And so there's the hero and the
adversary roughly speaking.
And you know,
there's all sorts of movies where the
protagonist is an Antihero,
you know,
and those movies are usually there to
show you bad examples in some sense.
Or you get mixed characters like Batman
and he's tangled up with the joker.
And as the joker points out in that
brilliant performance,
they're mirror images of one another.
And so
the jokers and adversary,
it's,
it's more complicated than that.
But so some of the symbols that commonly
represent the individual in symbolic
representations are while,
and also conceptual representations are
ego consciousness.
The trickster bugs bunny is a good
example of a trickster,
the fool,
the hero,
the coward spirit as opposed to matter
or as opposed to dogma,
the son,
the son of the unknown,
and the son of the king.
So,
and those are very,
very common figures.
And I'll walk you through some of that
as we progress today.
So,
and then there's the figure of the
adversary.
So you see on the right hand,
left hand side there,
you see.